so I want to do this once correctly and
then I want to move on we all know that
the impeachment trial against Donald
Trump was a sham and we also all knew
from the start that impeachment would
never remove Donald Trump that's not
what I want to argue about today if you
were connected to reality you understand
that it's not about evidence Republicans
were simply never going to really
consider a conviction in impeachment and
if you don't believe that you're not
going to be convinced by me I think we
can skip that altogether what I want to
go through just one time with you right
now is that in the days after his
acquittal Donald Trump is in pieces
admitted to the entire basis for the
impeachment which was previously denied
he didn't do it all at once
he certainly insists that everything
that was done is fine but he's
effectively admitted to everything and
the cherry on top was his admission over
the weekend that Donald Trump did indeed
send Rudy Giuliani to Ukraine looking
for dirt on Joe Biden that was the kind
of final reversal of the lies that had
been told all along so after we do this
we we no longer will have to deal with
the farcical argument that the stuffed
Trump is accused of doing he didn't do
he did it the argument is will he be
held accountable
is it impeachable is it wrong all of
that can be debated but the facts are
now very clear so let's start going
through this we've done individual clips
for a lot of these I'm not gonna play
every video here for you but you can
find our previous coverage on each of
these items that I'm going to mention
let's go through the claims one by one
it was claimed that Trump wanted
ambassador Murray Ivanovitch out because
she was interfering with what he wanted
to do - which was to get smear
investigations of Joe Biden Trump denied
it he said he barely knew who she was
all of that stuff that's been debunked
it was later confirmed that indeed Rudy
Giuliani admitted his role as Trump's
personal lawyer was to quote get her out
of the way referring to Murray
Ivanovitch we have the audio-visual
recording eventually released by Lev
Parnas Rudy Giuliani's henchmen in which
Parnas is talking to Trump about
Jovanovic and Trump turns to someone
else
the room and says take her out so that
defense is debunked Trump knew who she
was and wanted her out
second it was claimed that Trump was
seeking these investigations be
announced in to Joe Biden now Trump has
not denied this he has simply framed it
as I was trying to solve Ukrainian
corruption so this one's not even in
question the only question is was Joe
Biden one of trumps corruption related
concerns in Ukraine or was Trump really
concerned about corruption in Ukraine
and he was dabbling in a bunch of
different things investigations people
as we now know Trump never asked for any
other corruption related probe in
Ukraine about anything else
it was just Biden and he didn't even
really care about the investigation as
people have testified under oath during
the impeachment hearings Trump merely
wanted the investigation into Biden
announced those are not the actions of
someone concerned about corruption
generally so yes Trump wanted the Biden
smears and no corruption does not appear
to have been his concern and now
prominently Trump is admitting that he
did send Rudy Giuliani to Huntford dirt
on Joe Biden in Ukraine they are trying
to couch it as Trump knows Rudi is a
great tough investigator but Trump said
to Fox News personality Geraldo Rivera
in a podcast when asked whether it was
strange to send Rudi to Ukraine Trump
says he doesn't regret it and that Rudi
was acting on Trump's orders Trump
saying quote so when you tell me why did
I use Rudi and one of the things about
Rudi number one he was the best
prosecutor you know one of the best
prosecutors and the best mayor but also
other presidents had them FDR had a
lawyer who was practically you know was
totally involved with government
Eisenhower had a lawyer
they all had lawyers now this is a
complete red herring the other
presidents had lawyers that doesn't mean
they worked in a capacity to get foreign
countries to smear a potential opponent
of theirs for political gain or doesn't
mean they did any of these things but
again piece by piece
Trump admits at all Trump sent Rudi to
Ukraine for Biden investigations Trump
wanted Ukraine to announce Biden
investigations and didn't care about any
other investigations Trump wanted
Jovanovic out of the way and of course
importantly
Trump did order the military aid to
Ukraine withheld until an if Ukraine
announced the Biden investigations
ultimately they got caught so Trump
released the aide the trumpet's insists
the aide was released without the
investigations being announced so it's
all good this is like saying he failed
to commit the murder despite trying to
commit the murder because somebody
caught him in the act so therefore it's
not a crime it's not a defense
so consider the way that every claim has
fallen apart for months they said Rudy
wasn't there as a government operative
doing stuff for Trump and here is Tom
Trump telling Geraldo yeah I sent rudia
so the new defense is it all happened
but none of it is illegal the goal posts
moving and the standards changing before
our very eyes and on and on and on
rolling towards possible re-election
scary scary stuff I want to encourage
everybody in my audience to go subscribe
to a YouTube channel we're partnering
with it's called up flip they release
new videos every week in every video you
meet a different entrepreneur and get an
in-depth look at how their business
works and how they became successful
it's great if you like shows like Shark
Tank if you own your own business or
you're thinking of starting one the up
flip YouTube channel really does offer a
wealth of knowledge and inspiration as
an entrepreneur myself and a business
owner
I've really been enjoying hearing all of
the different stories of the people that
they interview but it's really
fascinating content even if you don't
own your own business to go check out
the up flip youtube channel they're
friends of the david pakman show i'd
love it if you would support them by
subscribing to their channel you can
find the up flip youtube channel by
going to david pakman.com slash up flip
you're watching this on youtube i've put
the link right underneath this video